oh you're an adrenaline rush kind of
person do you like doing crazy things I
do I love doing crazy things and that's
also why it's like very counterintuitive
and dangerous for me to be doing so many
dangerous things all the time like
skydiving and you do that really I do
yeah like fairly often or so as I can
yeah what else would you like to do
whoo gosh there's so many things I'd
like to do I did bungee jumping last
year which is probably the scariest
thing I've done would you do that in New
Zealand Wow
it's the highest bungee in the entire
world and it was the first time doing
something dangerous and crazy that I
actually uh looked like I seriously
considered not doing it I was so scared
yeah because with skydiving as scary as
it is you're strapped onto another
person and they're doing all the work
like you you're just kind of going along
for the ride it's like a roller coaster
right and then for a bungee jumping you
get strapped in you have to walk to the
legend you have to make the decision to
jump off yeah I actually asked them to
push me just push me I can't do it by
myself they're like we can't by law you
have to do yourself
actually I realize no they're not real
they're real guys we don't have guns in
Canada well go talk to the guys here
really so many guns and they're all
actually real they're all registered but
the bullets are blanks so they're not
real bullets but the guns themselves are
actual guns did you pick it up and
actually shoot one yeah I should have
got in this movie and I got had to do
gun training yeah and there's all these
like semi-automatic ones and then hand
guns and it's really cool I felt like a
badass yeah when we were on set with Vin
Diesel and Deepika uh you know so great
to talk to her about it because she was
talking about you guys you and Ruby Rose
and the fact there's such great women in
this film that must be pretty exciting
for you yeah it is really cool every
character is so unique and so different
and every person brings us into their
role and and there are very strong women
like the Dybbuk his role is so badass
Ruby's is so baller and for the techie
nerdy girl I actually love my characters
so much and and she's she's a really
cool arc I don't want to give away but I
probably make the biggest I change the
most of my art kind of she becomes a
different person by the end of the film
and so it's nice to be surrounded by
strong powerful women you know it's good
that we're finally depicting those women
in real life you know that's right in
their service yeah and there's a great
connection between you and Ruby Rose
because I thought George Clooney had
like the best pranks I take that back
because in the crab first of all did you
pick up those crabs and actually put it
in her trailer oh yeah yeah we did in
yourself we went to the to a supermarket
in the morning and I actually got do a
little bit of trouble because I think
some people thought that like we heard
the crabs I mean technically they were
in a supermarket they're gonna be
purchased to be to be eaten or taken to
a restaurants and we did eat them so
really good yeah they were delicious our
chef on the show served them to the crew
so I got Ruby and I got the
nice little lunch gift oh yeah
but ya know I love doing pranks I did a
lot of pranks when I was shooting
vampire diaries and now I'm coming here
I think it started with one day Ruby
said something about like nobody can get
her nobody can trick her oh yeah
challenge accepted if you ever would you
wish for because we were about to get
got a lot so it's her time to get back
to you now umm oh I haven't waited for
her to get me I just keep keep hitting
her which is best prank so far I think
the crab one was the best one I scared
her she got me pretty good though with
all the pictures she she printed off
over but over 200 photos of herself had
shots and covered my entire trailer with
them and then came in and accused me of
being obsessed with her world and I
loved hanging out with her and getting
to know her she's I'd heard so much
about Rubirosa
the Nate I mean her name alone we're
like you're a baller yeah but um but
then you meet her and she's a really
smart fun yeah wonderful woman with a
great head on her shoulder I was funny
and and very professional and takes
everything very seriously and she's been
a great friend and hopefully a lifelong
friend